and that was a good example of that game
David you talked about when the one Pawn
fell it the house went with it right and
and I think but Magnus also has a little
bit of that edge you you had you gave
the great Fisher quote where uh I don't
believe in Psychology I believe in moves
Magnus doesn't believe in fortresses he
believes in winning
um and you know these uh these guys um
those are great comparisons and I think
Magnus being a combo of the two is uh
really accurate but despite that
environment about not believing in
fortresses David we've seen him hold a
lot of games with fortresses yeah I did
a chessable course with him and I
brought up the fortresses topic Magnus
wasn't happy with me he was like stop it
stop it I know I said it once but yeah I
think he's uh he's got mixed feelings on
this now I think it was a great quote
actually I mean I I know I'm saying I
know Magnus has defended many games with
a fortress and he sort of set it in jest
and we hold on to things uh but at the
same time I mean the point is he he
doesn't believe in a lot of things
besides winning and he does that yeah
and before we Deep dive into this I have
for you if you had to give one advice to
not now taking on game two would it be
do not trade queens or what would it be
quite a rare move order but he's got
what he wants he's got this moroxy bind
we talked about it yesterday actually
Abdul satorov was on the white side of
this porn structure yesterday uh in one
of his games against Lebanon and
it looks like white does have this kind
of nice Pawn structure where you've
clamped down and black is the one who
has the onus of trying to break out
Magnus just moving instantly so far just
looks super confident I was just about
to highlight that because I think the
other comparison we can already draw
between this game and the second game
abducer Turf isn't taking time that says
like he's lost or anything but he's not
blitzing out the game right and he's not
he doesn't have more time that he
started with like some of these players
will when they're really in prep or he's
not nearly as up on the clock as he was
against aronian and again I think it's
indicative of the fact that Notre brick
of course knows these positions as part
of his opening repertoire but he wasn't
expecting it move orders he might try or
he'll just castle and improve us wrong
we'll see but I'm I'm suddenly surprised
by how much Magnus is thinking here and
indeed he does this Castle so
interesting that he took more than two
minutes there and eventually deciding
that he wants to park his King on the
king side very logical and Simon you
highlighted this move D5 wherever you go
I might just push my Pawn forward again
here I'm just tempted to take and it
looks like White's pieces look at them
they're just so centralized so ready for
the action to happen and this will be
okay wow Magnus is being more aggressive
right away not no uh leaving nothing to
the imagination here no subtleties in
terms of where he puts the pieces he's
all in with F4 E5 is a move you can
consider it looks a bit weird here
though to be honest it's really strange
because we're on moving
pieces bringing the king to safety while
the valbar does seem to creep up for
white but once again these kind of
positions can be so deceptive and for
black as well you want to hold might
sometimes want to jump to C6 to trade
off for this piece in the middle because
you are cramped you want to trade pieces
and he plays Knight to D7 it's heading
to C5 the other idea you mentioned move
carried the Jeep on love it it's coming
love it this is what we want to see just
going for the crush not messing around
right
even though a draw is probably fine for
Magnus he's in the lead right now he
wants to win he wants to end this match
as soon as possible second game of four
and G4 G5 I mean these top players
that's why they're so good they adapt to
the needs of the position we saw grinder
Magnus in the previous game now we're
seeing caveman Magnus just impressive
stuff we're going to see him continue
advancing those Pawns
yeah and and I mean the downside of that
move there you know uh the G Pawn is
that you do weaken the white king so at
some moment if white over extends we
talked about it's for those pawns that
move forwards they are your bodyguards
I've said this before they do look after
your king it's a deep dark Forest that
we were talking about Michael's Deep
Dark Forest complication where you bring
your opponent out and the path out is
narrow enough just for one to get out
and queen to F3 defending that Central
Pawn very often it does backfire you
sound like you play these positions as
black yeah I like that it's okay your
bias is creeping in and I think that's
okay yeah I think we might see that
happen Tanya and uh okay first Magnus
kicks the other night what is this why
are all the white pawns on the fourth
rank gaining so much space that's just
greedy pawns like he sets up his chairs
I love it um look he's playing fast here
and the eval is is slowly getting closer
to equal and I think your point on you
is is no I I I I didn't disagree I I
think that the position is aggressive
and white has a small Edge but these
positions are I'll put it this way I
think these positions are harder for
white than they are for black put that
dark Squad Bishop on G7 so one of the
Retreats is Bishop to f8 and Bishop to
G7 well hello go to back says no he buys
the bluff or was it a bluff David I
don't know if it was a bluff I would
have just taken the bait and asked
Magnus to prove it now I'm looking at
the fact that Magnus can at the very
minimum take this bishop off the board
is there something else okay I'm going
to dig deep here with our silicon
friends and Knight D5 wow after each D5
computer says what
[Laughter]
this is beyond most humans capabilities
but Magnus engines they see this type of
stuff another night lands and if this
Knight is captured the other night that
is incredible and the speed with which
Abdul satra refused to take that also
shows his understanding of these
positions you can part ways with the
dark Square Bishop even though you play
G6 right that's that's a scary thing to
do when you've got those holes on the
king side H6 and G7 and F6 all those all
those dark square holes so he
understands that there's no real way for
white to take advantage of that and and
that's kind of a deep understanding to
do that when most people I think would
be really afraid yeah Magnus it feels
like like you say Simon he was trying to
be too clever maybe and actually trading
off one set of minor pieces just makes
Black's position look so much more
attractive visually blacks the fact that
he's slightly cramped doesn't uh doesn't
oh it's not an issue now simply yeah
it's quite nice as well Queen d8 isn't
it it's a nice move to make yeah it's
kind of a pretty way too you've done it
once before in the game by the way
there you go it's good that we got our
expert here foreign
made some decent predictions today but I
was just asking for science I wasn't
suggesting I was asking for Science and
now he goes for it it might backfire for
Notre back right and it's a an
Affliction that all chess players should
avoid when you're nervous and and I feel
like Notre Beck saw a ghost there
because E5 is a panic mode aptitude's
kind of given him a helping hand and
okay Rook F7 looks like he's contorting
now to get his pieces over to protect
the black king the question is what does
Magnus do next is it your move Simon
just get rid of that Black Knight on H5
uh the kind of plug that's stemming the
flow on the king side right now it's not
easy for either side you can maybe go
after the Deep one as well but Black's
Queen will move Alex Queen has targets
as well on this side of the board he I
think he has gone off to the depot
switching to that one I'm waiting for
Magnus as well to push his pawn and
maybe switch the Bishops
that's full board awareness homes get
some yeah okay it might be coming soon
everybody
that could be quite uh and it's also so
much tension on the board I mean look at
what's happening on the king side with
that pawn face off the FNG pawns and
then there's also action on the center
and then the over extension on the queen
side there's a lot going on in the
position and he does get the bishop here
this also does give the possibility for
the C Pawn to advance one step ahead at
the right moment it's gonna it's gonna
blow up here in just a minute yeah and
the eval bar is deceptive there we go it
does drop because this position could
still go either way very very quickly
yep it's starting to open up now Magnus
taken a pawn there and moving his Bishop
in I mean and yeah time management it's
such a crucial part of these formats
yeah maybe we can get the engine
suggestions up right now does Abdus tour
of have to move his Rook away uh what
does the computer think because it to me
it looks like the stakes are high and
whoa
what a move if it's good or bad
it's a move all right the thing is now
you have some threats against your king
now suddenly this Pawn on e4 is attacked
one I would say queen H4 I would just go
back I'm such a genius I did
it comes to G4 now
actually and this is like I'm wearing
wow okay he's gone for it by the way
he's in this exact position so wow
taking the rock not focused like
pretending they're not under pressure
and only have a little bit I love how it
just zoned in he is and I love that we
need an update and I love you Windows
um but um Knight G3 has been nice
good good time for an update you know
time for an update most exciting
position we've maybe had all day and
windows comes along so long yeah I mean
you know who naughty bet reminds me of I
mean we've talked about Magnus and how
he reminds people of carpool from Bobby
Fischer but naughty bet reminds me of
Gary Kasparov there's no immediate
Checkmate on the board there's no way to
win the material back on the board but
he just keeps the tension you earned
that Advantage earlier in the game so
that in big moments like this and there
you go Notre big did not have enough
time to play The Right Move yeah while
Magnus now touching the one minute Mark
will he get rid of this Knight and he
does a great call there by PSY and picks
up the pawn the d-pawn is weak as well
and not the back which is 25 seconds on
the clock down two pawns now in the
position but he does pick up a key
Central Pawn I didn't see Knight takes
people but you know that simple move why
they're so good they see one move deeper
Magnus had foreseen that he's dropping
the e-pawn but he just gets his King out
of Dodge the white king now is actually
just running away and okay nice pin
there from madridorah don't pick up that
Black Knight The White Knight is needed
to block the G file there's Checkmate
threats there it's crazy crazy position
I'm not really a played by both sides
brilliant I mean they're both under a
minute now and it's only a one Pawn
advantage and Magnus giving the pawn
back now I think it's a great idea if he
gets to the end game he's he's the only
player who can win and we know he loves
the end game and if Knight takes well
then now D6 Falls I think you could
probably take both ways but Rook take
seems to be the not about just avoiding
any Queen trades here he has to go for
magnus's King yeah but Rook takes D6 is
Rook f8s isn't I mean it's it's such a
wild position this that again the
evaluation bar I think is misleading and
they're both so short of time I wonder
if Queen takes is better so that if the
Knight moves you can play Queen D4 and
get the Queens off the board nice Danny
I think that might be the key the White
Queen and King William both lined up on
the FL you needed to move one of them
there would have been too many tactics
as Simon pointed out look now the
evaluation bar is pretty easy we've
removed those you just walk through the
king to the center of the board anyone's
getting this I like that because now
he'll take the Queens off the board even
if he doesn't win the D6 Pawn I think he
might have tried to play Queen D4 just
using the Practical Edge but what is
that a win he's just Queen D6 yeah four
seconds and look at he reacts he knows
he's made a mistake he goes back first
mistake of the game in terms of uh
practical play there he just lost a pawn
with gain of tempo but the queen guards
G1 now so Knight F5 is on the agenda oh
he's just swapping off uh that was a
shame one second and did he get flat oh
under one second when he made that move
but it's not gonna help him here two
pawns down and he's had to retreat his
Knight attack has gone this is a
mathematics equation now
look at the Queen's board geometry she
doesn't guard G1 anymore but she guards
G5 so there's no more checks that follow
although King F1 would have allowed
Queen H3 so Magnus is very careful and
this queen
he didn't he lost on time yeah he's
losing right here
loses on the clock
what a game what a win an absolute wild
right there